welcome back for our series the dish we
are revisiting a story about the cuisine
of Afghanistan and how many recipes
there have been passed down from
generation to generation family to
family and mother to daughter we first
told you back in March about a couple
with roots in Afghanistan updating that
tradition in their successful Washington
area restaurants the masraw family
decided to put women in the family front
and center John Crawford shows us their
powerful message about food and female
empowerment
when Sophia mesurer is making her famous
leak and scallion dumplings she smiles I
just love it because it reminds me of my
childhood it's my all-time favorite dish
it's childhood that began in Afghanistan
before her family fled to the United
States after the Soviet invasion when
the country was a Cosmopolitan
celebration of cultures my mother when
she would make this dish my favorite
part was to do this oh really yes sit
around the dining room table and we
would stuff the wrappers the delicate
leak and scallion dumplings are just one
of the classic dishes featured in Sophia
and husband Omar's Washington DC area
Afghan restaurants which they started as
a way to share their country's
sophisticated Cuisine every African
restaurant you would go to was just
Kebab Kebab kebab which is not the
tradition it's not traditional there's
so much more there's so much more to
Afghan food food influenced by the many
cultures that formed Afghanistan food
that's going to be coming from Central
Asia you know from China India the
Persians so it's a mixture of of
everything this food is like Afghanistan
a combination of cultures and different
ethnicities and backgrounds all coming
together in like a beautiful Harmony
which country that you can go to or
which nation you could go to there you
could get a rice dish that's gonna have
raisins in there that's gonna have
carrots in there that's going to have
almonds walnuts meat pistachios
today Afghanistan is anything but
harmonious
seeing it return to Taliban control LED
them as rulers to make a statement last
fall that went well beyond food
Omar decided to step back from the
operations and put the women his wife's
sister and his two oldest daughters in
charge I said listen the only way to do
a change or to make a statement is you
have to from inside to do something not
through words not through anything but
through action
what was the statement that you were
trying to make them women can do
anything oldest daughter Talia is the
new manager of Bistro aracasia running
all the restaurants day-to-day
operations Oman is manager and training
at the McLean location sometimes people
ask me for the manager and I'm like well
I am the manager what does it mean to
you to kind of be a part of this
statement that you're making oh it makes
me feel good that they think that I can
manage a restaurant and run a restaurant
I want to be CEO of the restaurants and
just learn how to do everything
the critically acclaimed restaurants the
women now in charge continue to expand
locations they attribute their success
to the customers and the recipes that
span Generations from one mother to the
next I mean I learned this from my
mother so that's how she made it that's
how I made it and that's how I'm
teaching
others to make it and now passing again
to the next what is your dream for your
your daughters
[Music]
as they grow up to know who they are
that's all I just want them to to to
know that they could do anything they
want to do they can run a business they
can be a CEO better better well what's
your dream for their futures for them to
you know be confident believe in
themselves
be kind human beings you know it's just
also it's not just about them it's about
everyone and for all those other girls
needing to hear you can do it Jan
Crawford CBS mornings McLean Virginia
beautiful get those reservations now
that's making me hungry already I know
ready to eat I'm ready